[Music]
i didn't think i'd live to see the day
that you would have a uh a tmz clip
go viral but uh you were captured
recently by tmz
uh in a in a parking garage
having a little bit of a meltdown uh
because you couldn't get the gate arm to
open should we just show the footage
first and then discuss sure all right
let's take a look at
larry david unable to exit a parking
garage
[Applause]
larry david
it says five dollars
[Music]
all right now
nice nice work
all right so
so what happened there
i was with my kids we just come from
dinner i was in a garage yes i parked
the car
and i had i had a ticket okay
and they told me the first two hours are
free yes so
you know i drove up to the exit i
followed the cars
and it was one of those automated gates
that go up and down there was nobody
there and i i tried to put the ticket in
but it
you know it wouldn't it wouldn't fit in
a slot yes and it said you owe five
dollars and i'm i'm yelling i got it
i get two hours for free you know
and i get no answer you know it's a
machine it's a machine i get no answer
no answer
what happens when you yell at your
coffee pot how did that go i thought
maybe somebody was overseeing this yes
yes i understand we left our own devices
yes
yes so i take out my wallet and i try
and stick a five dollar bill in there
but it doesn't fit right yeah we'll not
it will not accept the five dollar bill
don't accept
you know i realized that
there's an army behind me waiting to get
out a lot of cars piled up yes a lot of
cars piled up so
i thought i need to get out and talk to
them
so you know i got what are you yelling
you're yelling i can't do it i can't do
it what are you yelling i can't do it i
i can't i don't know how to work the
machine
that wasn't we cannot because i thought
they were gonna beat me to death you
know because people in la they're
impatient they want to just get where
they're going yes and and and so then
this woman
was kind enough to get out of her car
and help she said you need a credit card
oh credit card yeah that does it credit
card yeah
now what was the what's the credit card
i mean had you known it was a credit
card would that have gone smoothly
oh no no no she she had to do it for me
yeah well it's just a quick swipe
i'm not a good swiper connor yeah you
can't swipe things no i can't swipe and
you know something
if you had told me
years ago that i would be a bad swiper
i wouldn't have believed it
as a young lad i said one day
mr david you will be a bad swiper you
wouldn't believe it wouldn't believed it
but um as it turns out i can't i'm a
terrible swiper and i'm always
i'm constantly holding up lines and you
know supermarkets
gas stations gas stations in particular
what is the pump it's a quick
that's all it is no there's four
different ways to to put it in
you got this way and then i turn it
upside down and then i reverse it
there's four you could get through all
four pretty quickly and get to the right
one somehow it feels like if you do two
or three it negates it you have to go
back
your life is a living
hell well no there's some swiping
problems
otherwise i'm potent you know
if if there was impotency then it would
be a living hell yes yes
okay we have to that's a living hell uh
it must be awful yeah it is great
i wouldn't know boy not me i've had it
and it
you had it and it went away it went away
yeah you were impotent
once or twice
it happened and i could tell you
it was a living hell
i didn't know what to do
you just never can do it it's not just
the momentary inability no you have to
go through this apology this oh we've
all been there yeah oh you go oh jeez oh
my god oh jesus you don't you talk for a
long time about it
you have to discuss it
it's an elephant in the room